le sénateur pierre hugues boisvenu
revient à la charge en déposant pour une
troisième fois un projet de loi qui vise
une modification au code criminel une
modification qui aiderait les jurés
traumatisé obtenir du soutien
psychologique au terme d'un procès on
reçoit monsieur boisvenu bonjour mais
l'embauché bonne journée aujourd'hui à
tous les gens qui sont avec nous ce
matin dans quelle mesure monsieur
boisvenu votre projet de loi aiderait
les zurich ont besoin de soutien
il faut comprendre que l'article 649 du
code criminel ne permet pas un membre de
jury de dire quelques informations qu'il
a reçues entendu ou vu lors des
délibérations
parce qu'on sait que l'édile au canada
contrairement aux américains les
délibérations de gérer au canada sont
tout à fait confidentiel et de donner de
l'information qu'on a obtenus dans ces
délibérations là c'est un acte criminel
en vertu de cet article est donc en 2006
ma mémoire est bonne en 2017 et un
comité le comité des ressources humaines
ou des
déçus mais je pense de la chambre des
communes a fait une étude sur la maladie
mentale et les traumatismes que les gens
peu vives et les gens qui participaient
à des jurys est devenu comme un espèce
d'évidence que ces gens là lors ce
qu'ils assistaient je pense entre autres
à tina danseurs qui est avec nous ce
matin qui a cité comme jury dans le
procès de bernard blot est la sortie de
ce procès l'a traumatisée avec les
images que le vu des témoignages que le
vus en plus d'avoir délibéré pour
condamner cet individu doit donc ces
gens là sorte de procès et le jus c'est
souvent voit les oubliés alors qu'ils
sont une pièce maîtresse de notre
système de justice et aussi ce soient
des citoyens qu'on appelle à entendre un
procès pour rendre une décision les
jurys sont au coeur de la décision qu'un
procès lors d'un procès et ces gens là
souvent n'ont pas la formation c'est
monsieur madame tout le monde et de
sortir de l'expérience va encore durer
des semaines ben c'est jallet sur
traumatisée et elles n'ont pas le droit
d'aller chercher de l'aide psychologique
ou psychiatrique peu importe la nature
et de dévoiler aux professionnels ce
qu'elle a vu ce que l'on a entendu lors
des délibérations alors je pense que
l'étude au parlement un devoir enfin oui
je vous comprend là dessus monsieur
boisvenu mais il ya le secret des
délibérations mais qu'est-ce qui vous
portent à penser que le traumatisme des
jurys vielles du secret des
délibérations alors que ce sont les
effets d'une cause qui sont
traumatisants dans bernardo les vidéos
c'était diffusé en pleine quo dans man
iota aussi les témoignages sont en plein
cours tout ça ils ont le droit d'en
discuter ça fait partie de la preuve qui
a été dévoilée devant tout le monde
alors en quoi le secret des
délibérations en particulier traumatise
les jurés c'est une partie ce que je
discutais ce matin avec les témoins avec
monsieur farenc et président de
l'association canadienne les membres de
jury et il me dit aussi beaucoup de
jurés qui doivent à cette impression
beaucoup de pression de la part de leur
entreprise là un peu de l'entreprise
pour quitter l'entreprise pendant des
semaines et souvent il y en a qui vont
perdre leur emploi donc ça ajoute au
stress le fed est isolé pendant des
semaines et de devoir
gérer et challenge et par rapport à
notre perception qu'on a de la
culpabilité ou non du cadeau saucisses
et ajoute au stress et de sortir de la
cour est d'avoir aussi le fardeau de
dire si j'en parle à quelqu'un je comme
un acte criminel donc c'est un ensemble
de faits ou on met des gens comme je
disais tantôt souvent qu'ils n'ont pas
la formation pour traverser ces étapes
là sans séquelles et une fois que c'est
l'inversé on les laisse tomber donc ce
qu'on va faire tout simplement c'est
dire à ces gens là vous pouvez consulter
un professionnel
le professionnel est lié par le secret
professionnel donc on est certain que
cette information le niveau pop loin que
le bureau du professionnel et sa formule
permettre à des gens de ne pas vivre
pendant des années des années ce
traumatisme la la sénatrice qui appuie
ce projet de loi là avec moi qui la
critique puis presque coco marraine si
je peux apprendre d'expression c'est la
sénatrice mention que vécu un tel ou tel
évènement il ya 29 ans et elle nous
parlait ce matin encore de son
expérience à lui a pris des années à se
sortir de 2,7 ce drame lors de ce choc
là et il se porte elle aussi je veux
dire elle est une ardente défenseure las
de supporter les jurés lorsqu'ils vivent
ces expériences dites moi monsieur
boisvenu à l'heure actuelle quand on a
aussi et j'ai comme juré au canada ont
pu recevoir de l'aide psychologique mais
c'est chaque province qui gère son
programme séparément est-ce que ça c'est
il ya aussi un manque d'uniformité ce
serait intéressant que ça relève d'une
loi uniforme au pays vous avez raison et
on en discute actuellement que ministre
je sais jamais discuté que monsieur les
médecines lors de la dernière session
avant l'élection d'une part
d'uniformiser les services et d'autre
part aussi de financer des services
c'est bien beau de dire au jury vont
chercher de lights yvonne ali service
public va attendre un ou deux alors que
si vos privé mais il y avait des
déboursés donc on regarde en même temps
comment le gouvernement fédéral pourrait
financer ces services là pour nous
assurer qu'un jury qui demandent de
l'aide qu'ils n'aient pas à attendre des
mois et des mois avant de la recevoir
mais qui peut s'allier au privé il
recevoir rapidement ce sport c'est
l'humain eh bien on va on va évidemment
suivre et on compte sur vous parce que
vous lâchez pas le morceau absolument on
espère qu'elle se moque on laisse moi
ici modja prochain s est posé sur toile
soit adoptée car la chose
pour nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit